it's always nice to have a little shine
you know just not enough for people to
be like oh well this guy's an
obnoxious kid but it's also enough like
oh [ __ ] he's
he's got he's got some
hey what's up everybody it's the kid
leroy and these are my essentials
my first essential is actually these
sunglasses right here
these are louis vuitton shades i got
these out here in la
it's hard for me to find like sunnies
that like fit my face
really nice so these are like my
favorite right now they're kind of like
my basic like everyday type of joints
shades are essential for me they make me
feel a little more uh
they make me feel comfortable and
especially when i go into like places
with a lot of people
i tend to like start like freaking out a
little
so um yeah the shades definitely boost
my confidence a little and uh
yeah i love them so this is definitely
an essential for me
i have a lot of shades i don't wear a
lot of different shades but i definitely
i definitely have a lot of them
at home in my closet like over over 20
pairs of shades but i mainly stick to
the
the louise and the and the salines to be
honest these
i think right now my favorite because
they fit my face really good
so the next essential is this little guy
right here
let me let me take it off this right
here
is a chain it's like a little baguette
chain thingamajig
that i got just this trip when i was in
new york
for snl actually i always wanted one of
these chains i never had enough money to
to comfortably get one i hit up elliott
and this has just been a chain that i
loved for the longest time i just love
the style and i like how it's like not
too
out there because i'm not like a super
out there type of guy
i do like a little little ice here and
there so um this is like perfect for me
it still it suits me and it and it
doesn't look like i'm doing too much or
do something else so yeah this is
definitely an essential for me i wear
this like i've worn this every day
i think since i've uh since i've come
back from new york so yeah
essential all right so next up i have
this uh
it's a chanel 2005 vintage sports bag
designed by carl lagerfield who was uh
one of my favorite designers rest in
peace he was uh he was incredible
i'm very like uh i wouldn't like to say
cheap but i'm very like frugal
with my money you know i don't like to
spend my money on like
on dumb stuff i don't want to be broke
so
i try to keep my money nice and put it
in the right places
and i actually have like a a picture
of karl lagerfield in my room like not
just like a soul portrait picture of him
so i was just like you know what it's
meant to be
i'm gonna grab it and um so yeah here it
is
the chanel gym bag my next stuff is
actually
i put it all in this bag so um so yeah
the next thing i'd like to pull out
would be uh
cologne
[Music]
this one is chanel this is actually what
i got on right now
the other one that i've been using a lot
of recently is this like versace one
just like my shades um i have a
ton of cologne at home i have like hella
ones that's just like sitting in the box
i'm kind of a cologne freak i don't know
i like i like smelling good i like you
know
i like that oh hey what's up hey you
know they're like oh man yeah like
you smell good and i'm like oh i don't
know it makes me feel it makes me feel
better about myself
i actually have a funny story though
about a cologne that's one of my
favorites that i actually don't have
because i ran out of it the other day
it says ysl cologne i was going to my
girlfriend's house
one day and like she has a security at
the front of her house right
and the security's there and he's like
he's like
i'm like oh what's up man he's like um
is that
ysl any like named the exact cologne
that i was wearing and i was like oh
[ __ ]
how'd you know and he's like yeah he's
like and he told me he's like this like
[ __ ]
cologne connoisseur or some [ __ ] and i
was like yo i don't know i just think
cologne's a great thing to have i think
it's always nice to smell good it always
pays
my next essential would have to be
this book right here this book is the 48
laws of power
i've actually read this book two or
three times it's helped me
so much just in life in general but
especially in like the industry i'm in
after i read it i kind of took it in as
more of something to kind of
watch how other people use this and how
to protect yourself as opposed to like
using this and like using it because
it's a you can cut
it's pretty evil when you get into it if
you if you use this
so after reading this book i pick up a
lot of different stuff that people try
and pull and i'm like ah
you funny [ __ ] so the reason
this book
actually looks really new is because it
is really new
i actually don't read i actually
listened to the audio books
but i just thought i'd pick up this
because it would be kind of weird if i
was like gonna like
show you my phone and whatever but yeah
i read this as an audio book but
uh i guess now i have the hard copy so
uh
yeah the next essential i have
these bad boys right here tim tams
this is an australian thing these are
probably like the greatest thing
in the entire world and i don't think
like anything in america can like
come close and they're actually one of
the hardest biscuits to find over here
because um
they're so good that like every foreign
or like world market
actually sells out of these as soon as
they come in so these are really hard to
find
i'm lucky i could find them for today
though because i was like
i was running low at the crib and i
didn't want to bring one tim tam so i
i was lucky to find a whole pack of beer
they're chocolatey but they're kind of
like a chocolate and like a
like a wafer biscuit or something i
don't dude i don't
know all i know is that they taste
incredible so if you haven't had them go
and get them
this is not an ad i'm not sponsored i
just generally love
kind of these things so yeah this is 100
an essential and it kind of makes me
feel like i'm at home a little bit when
i eat these next essential
okay this one's pretty self-explanatory
but this is a portable charging block
i don't know i use my phone a lot some
days i'm out and i'm not home for like
hours and if my phone runs low and
i need to charge it then here we go we
got this and it's pretty
easy just i usually put this like in my
back pocket or
um i'll give it to one of my boys and
they'll just like hold it in their
pocket with my phone on charge
if i if my phone's not like at least
halfway charged i feel [ __ ] like
i feel weird like like leaving the house
in the morning so i was gonna charge my
phone overnight
just because i like to know that if
something goes wrong i'm like a really
paranoid kind of kind of person for
whatever reason so i always think like
oh what if something goes wrong and my
phone's dead and that's the only way i
can
get out of this something wrong and like
it's dead and now like i'm
so yeah i love having my phone charged
the next one
is uh it's like a protein shaker
raps trainer is my boy who trains me
he's the
goat people who don't know me should
know that i'm in the gym a lot i try to
go every morning
at least and i'm super serious about
fitness
i can't really go through my day without
having a protein shake off to the gym i
kind of
kind of makes me feel weird so uh this
is something like five days a week
at least that i'm using this thing
called high protein and this is kind of
like
a natural protein that is like it's made
from crickets it's made from crickets so
it's like it hasn't got all the there's
like that whole thing about you know
like
regular protein shakes so like they can
like create cancers and [ __ ] like that
but i guess
this is kind of like not that and uh the
guy who trains me raps trainer my boy
this is something that he swears by i
definitely like the taste of the gnc one
better
but uh i i would i would assume this is
better for you so uh yeah but this is
something that my trainer lives by so
i don't know i just [ __ ] listen to
him all right let's get rid of this
bag
[Music]
this bad boy right here is my ps5
my playstation 5.
this is an essential for my day i mean
like whenever i go home
and uh and i have some chill time i'm
right in my bedroom playing this
i'm playing 2k because i'm trying to get
really good
growing up i was terrible at games and i
i never really played games that much
and yeah
at least i i wasn't good at them at all
now in my
in my free time i've just become a 2k
addict and now i'm like
trying to be like the greatest 2k player
of all time and
i i don't know i'd like to think i'm on
my way we also set this
up in the snl dressing room i had to be
there
from like what like noon until like 1am
and because i was like a feature and it
wasn't my actual thing there was a lot
of time where i was just sitting around
i there was only like two hours i was
actually doing something two or three
hours so all that all in between there
it
gets [ __ ] boring not with this thing
though we had this [ __ ] hooked up
i was [ __ ] up everyone oh and this is
also just like a case that
i recently got for the ps5 just for
traveling because i was putting this
in my suitcase and it was taken up a lot
of room
so i was like i'll just get a case that
i can carry on and like take
with me everywhere by last essential um
this might be the corniest essential
you've ever had
on your entire show but i would like to
say my family
it's my last essential and my mom and my
younger brother
being from australia coming over here to
the in
united states of america it's really
hard and like i was over here for like
almost six months by myself and it felt
really lonely and i
really missed them a lot so then when i
finally got the chance to bring them out
here it just made my life so much
easier and better and yeah so i would
say that's definitely my loss essential
my family
thank you guys for having me this is
literally one of my favorite youtube
shows and i've been wondering for a
minute when you guys were gonna
if you guys were gonna ring me up and
tell me to come pause i'm happy you did
thank you
all right well there you go everyone
those are my intent essentials i hope
you guys
enjoyed it and i hope you guys didn't
get too bored if any of you guys
want to get in school in 2k hit me in
three months because right now i'm not
that good but three months and i'll be
off my
way so yeah